it's been nearly a year since the
taliban returned to power in afghanistan
the group says the nation is moving
forward but millions of people are
hungry many girls aren't in school and
few countries recognize the taliban's
leadership so what's needed to turn
things around this is inside story
[Music]
[Music]
hello there and welcome to the program
i'm nastasia tay the taliban's swift
return to power in afghanistan a year
ago caught many by surprise the group
captured a string of cities as u.s led
foreign forces left the country after 20
years and when its fighters took over
the presidential palace on august 15
president ashraf ghani went into exile
conceding the taliban has won
tens of thousands of afghans and
foreigners scrambled to kabul airport to
board those last flights out taliban
leaders promised to be more moderate and
said they were committed to respecting
women's rights but 12 months on most
girls are still banned from school
females have limited rights to work or
travel without a male guardian and
afghanistan's economy has nearly
collapsed with foreign aid drying up
speaking exclusively to al jazeera a
senior taliban leader called for more
international support
it has been only one year since we
assumed power and the world should not
expect us to achieve all our goals
overnight it is next to impossible
especially when the international
community has not fulfilled promises
including recognition of our rule and
foreign aid despite the delay on their
part we by the grace of god achieved
huge progress on many fronts
well afghanistan's economic crisis has
worsened its already dire humanitarian
situation nearly one million afghans
have lost or been forced from their jobs
since the taliban took over according to
the world food programme 90 of afghans
have faced food shortages over the past
year the world bank says the prices of
consumer products such as diesel flour
rice and sugar have increased 50 percent
since last year and afghanistan has nine
billion dollars in reserves but they're
held in the u.s and europe that's
because the international community
refuses to recognize the taliban
government
well let's now bring in our guests in
kabul we have muskeglani she is the
acting director of the afghanistan women
council and in london is graeme smith
he's a senior consultant on afghanistan
for international crisis group he's also
the author of the dogs are eating them
now our war in afghanistan a warm
welcome to you both musk i want to start
with you because you're sitting in kabul
at the moment after what we heard from
the taliban a year ago all those
promises are you surprised by what life
is like there now
um first of all i would like to say
hello to our panel member um and
when you ask me if i'm surprised
absolutely not i am not surprised
uh the way the situation of the country
is right now the past year's experience
has shown that the taliban have not only
remained unchanged but they also act
with far more extreme ideology advice to
deprive freedoms and sabotage the
foundations of national
unity in afghanistan
there's open oppression against women
depriving them from their rights taking
away their the rights from children and
youth
of this country of education and along
with it topping it all up with ethnic
discrimination they have promised far
more different things but
they have not um at all come across into
fulfilling any of those promises
unfortunately and um
it just feels like all those promises
were uh were lies um i mean these all
that we see or
have seen in the past one year are all
examples of their fanatic and radical
thinking
which is truly according to me bizarre
one of the big promises that they made
was obviously around women's rights
about allowing women to continue working
going to school especially and obviously
back in march they stopped most girls
from being allowed to go to secondary
school
graham i'm curious because at the
beginning of the taliban taking power
they were very keen to reassure the
international community and they wanted
legitimacy they wanted aid why did they
make this decision in march
well yeah i was
i was there in doha on the sidelines of
the negotiations
the taliban were
trying to
reassure the international community as
you say
but i think it's worth going back and
looking at
what exactly they promised because
even though they were trying to indicate
that they are ready to have peaceful
relations with the outside world and and
even sort of courting uh foreign
investment they were always very careful
to say that uh what they call a domestic
issues uh you know issues of social
policy for example in which they're
extremely conservative
uh that these are things that the
outside world should not interfere with
and so i i feel you know i've never
myself you know used this phrase taliban
2.0 that you sometimes hear because in
my view the taliban have always been the
taliban and so there is actually a fair
bit of consistency between what they uh
said earlier and what they're doing now
you're right though that there was a
kind of turning point in march when the
taliban decided to officially bar
girls from secondary schools now of
course in about half the provinces or so
girls are actually attending secondary
schools but but officially across the
country that ban remains in place and
um you know i think that was a moment
where you saw the emir and circles
around the emir the supreme leader down
in kandahar really trying to assert
themselves within the movement and so
one year into the evolution of the
taliban regime it's still very much a
working progress in terms of who's in
control and how it all works well given
the splits then that we're seeing within
the taliban themselves uh musca let me
ask you is this causing division on the
ground within communities
um well um within communities no because
when you look at it as
as communities they all want the same
thing in the end of the day i think
there are different ideas and their
different uh
ideologies or or different decisions is
only putting um them among themselves
like in trouble and making them not get
along uh among each other which is again
really surprising to to like it does not
make sense to any of us what they fought
for 20 years and then they come back
and all their focus is on
being just strict towards women and
that's all that they have been doing and
they have paid absolutely no attention
to the economic crisis that's been uh
that this country has been dealing with
so i think if you look at it like from a
step back the entire community all the
communities um
uh in in afghanistan they all want the
same thing so no it does not really
divide them it just puts them in a lot
of concern sure i want to get to the
economic concerns and the situation
there in a moment but
this whole situation with girls going to
school and and this ban on girls going
to secondary school this has had huge
implications for aid so muska as someone
who works with women in afghanistan i'm
curious about your personal opinion do
you think foreign donors should be
withholding aid until the taliban
changes its policy on women and girls
um
i personally think no because it is not
it's not helping
the government is not breaking
the help is not coming the only people
suffering in the middle are the woman
that we personally have been working
with or all the women as a matter of
fact i mean
which part of women being on the roads
begging is better than
um like
getting no aid like it makes no sense so
i think no i think the international
community should
actually
um
send in their donations but maybe
not through the government because
honestly in my opinion this government
should not be recognized
so i want to bring graham in here as
well because i know you have called for
aid to be released and obviously western
governments don't want to look like they
are supporting the taliban how is this
now being discussed in in western
capitals yeah my organization the
international crisis group was one of
the sort of earliest to come out
publicly last fall and say look um this
is not going to work uh you know there
are a lot of hungry people in
afghanistan and so it's probably time to
start thinking about unfreezing the
frozen assets
about lifting some of the
western economic restrictions especially
easing the effects of sanctions
and to their credit actually uh western
actors especially the united states have
been taking steps in that direction i
mean this spring we saw something called
general license 20 from the u.s treasury
department that's actually the most
sweeping set of exemptions from u.s
sanctions anywhere in the world so there
have been the this kind of you know
effort to
to ease the blow a little bit but it's
still very much a work in progress those
assets remain frozen as you mentioned at
the top of the show
and uh those negotiations are continuing
between uh the united states and the
taliban about the future of central
banking which sounds like a boring topic
but it's just vital to how afghans eat
there needs to be cash liquidity on the
streets so that the import deals can get
done so that you know daily bread can
reach uh afghan bakeries
so well let's talk about what that looks
like on the streets of kabul musca you
alluded to the economic crisis there
what does a regular day look like at the
moment
the regular day it um
it's disappointing it's painful and it's
heartbreaking um those those are all
that i can say but um
behind every
bread bakery that you see there are 20
to 20 25 30 women just sitting there
waiting for someone to give them a piece
of bread that's what's happening
children are out on the streets begging
all day long
most of these women were the only
breadwinners of their family since their
husbands or brothers or fathers have
been killed or died or
all
during these 20 years of war so they
were the main
breadwinners and now
a daily
normal day in kabul or in afghanistan
overall looks like
this sad tragedy where women are out
with their hands out begging for 10 apps
20 amps a piece of bread a little bit of
food so they could go back home and feed
their children that's what it looks like
well we keep talking about food security
and i recall
last winter we were talking very much
about the possibility of a famine in
afghanistan going into the lean season
it does seem that somehow that was
staved off graham how how did that
actually happen and obviously there's
there's winter coming again this year
but what is the situation like at the
moment
i mean it was staved off just barely
uh the united nations says that upwards
of 20 000 people in the central
highlands are now in what they call
famine-like conditions that's sort of
the very worst kind of starvation-like
category
and there's i think there's a real fear
that that could spread
as we get towards winter afghanistan of
course produces a lot of its own food
in the harvest seasons and then when you
get towards winter it depends a lot more
on imports those imports are now more
expensive globally partly because of the
war in ukraine and partly because of the
paralysis in the banking sector it's
very hard for food importers to bring
food into the country like they did
before and some of the the blockages uh
to to trade
are resulting in higher prices for for
ordinary afghans as you noted um you
know just terrible inflation not just in
the price of food the price of fuel the
prices of medicine
and so uh there really does have to be
some greater action
um in terms of uh reaching some kind of
agreement between the west and the
taliban on how economic revival is going
to be achieved moscow correct me if i'm
wrong i understand that there is food to
be bought in the market so it is
available it's just that people don't
have the money to buy it and i know
there have been some issues about
salaries being paid so can you give us
an idea of just how big that gap is
between the price of food and what
people can actually afford
um well the price of food has got
has gone really high
um of course and but the thing is that
currently half of the
the people or women that we're working
since i come and i am
basically representing the women right
now but the women used to work and now
they have been fired from their jobs so
they're not really getting salaries and
if they were the breadwinners it's
really hard uh so that gap is like
really really really big um
and so um i mean i really don't know how
this is gonna this is gonna change um
because um also the donations that so
far have come in um to help uh the
people who are dealing with uh with such
issues it has only made afghanistan look
like a charity case and that's not what
we want we want something stable we want
something
for everyone to have their rights to
right to work right education right to
just equal rights for men and women um
currently most men are not being paid
most of their salaries are not given so
i mean
people literally don't have money to go
and buy
and
enough for for their families so they're
dealing with quite a hard time right now
some of the most extreme needs that
we've been seeing are in rural areas as
well so many people though outside kabul
just wanted the fighting to stop so now
we're seeing this relative peace at the
same time as economic challenges and
mounting graham how are people outside
kabul viewing the taliban now given this
kind of dichotomous situation they're in
well you know
as you mentioned
shutting millions of girls out of high
schools
really hasn't helped the taliban's
reputation
i think the discovery of al qaeda leader
ayman al-zawahiri living in the heart of
kabul also damaged the taliban's
reputation globally
and so uh it gets harder under those
conditions um for the taliban to reach
any kind of
um agreement about how to get beyond
just sort of short-term emergency relief
which is neither you know sustainable
nor sufficient to deal with the tens of
millions of afghans who are now in the
brink of starvation
you know what the world bank has said is
that we need to start investing in
development that for example
there is less area under effective
irrigation today than there was in the
1970s
it's a primarily agricultural economy so
you know there needs to be help with
getting water to crops uh but you know
who is going to come in and build a
large-scale irrigation system
uh under a taliban regime that is not
recognized by the international
community and
um you know with the sort of political
distance growing and so it's
um it really is a a difficult situation
graham i i really want to focus on how
people in rural areas particularly
feeling as well because i know you've
traveled around the country i mean in
the last few months or so and i'm
curious about how people who were really
just wanting the fighting to stop how
they're feeling now that they're faced
with the taliban regime even though
there is a now relative security
yeah i just
finished working with colleagues on a
report about the security situation
based on interviews in 13 out of the 34
provinces
a lot of people in rural areas are
benefiting from
the end of the war essentially there are
two small insurgencies remaining one
against remnants of the former republic
in the north and one against the local
version of the islamic state in the east
but these are really small scale uh
conflicts and you know this had been the
deadliest war on the planet earth we had
thirty thousand to forty thousand people
uh dying annually in the conflict
hundreds of thousands displaced and so
yeah in a lot of the the rural villages
people are are putting their lives back
together they're picking up the pieces
literally
um some of the the biggest threats to
civilians in those areas are when
children pick up the explosive remnants
of war they're they're foraging for
scrap metal or they're playing with the
shiny bits of metal and something
explodes and so far too many children
unfortunately uh are dying uh in the
remnants of this terrible conflict
musket you're sitting in kabul do you
feel like there's still a huge huge
difference between how people feel in
the capital versus in the rural areas
particularly now that the security
situation has changed
honestly i think right now everyone is
starving be it the capital be it the
rural areas everyone's focus is to have
their tummies filled uh food on their
table um security
i mean
what i mean
it does not feel secure so what's the
point of this kind of a security okay
yes we're not having explosions the way
we used to but they are they were the
ones who were doing the explosions
themselves so i mean that is not that
big of a
good news that oh explosions or the
security has uh
gotten better um but right now as
a whole the whole nation right now is
starving and that's their biggest
biggest issue right now at hand um
i mean if you really think about it what
good does this security bring if they're
all starving and are dealing with
depression or anxiety or
a hundred other issues that they face on
daily basis well amid all the criticism
that the taliban's received they've said
that their big focus has been on
security and graham as you alluded to
there they are still fighting a number
of groups including isil what do you
think their focus is now are they being
distracted by by military operations are
they wanting to focus on the economic
situation
the taliban are in the middle of
consolidating control both militarily
and economically
um yes as you say uh they are still
struggling against uh
some you could call them insurgent
groups um they are actually gaining the
upper hand against
these uh pockets of resistance but they
they do continue
uh
economically uh
they have uh just
dismantled some of the checkpoints um
you know when you drive
around the highways uh
some of the places where the police used
to shake down truck drivers those places
simply don't exist anymore
and some very uh careful satellite-based
work examining flows through customs
houses has shown that the taliban have
cleaned up more than a billion dollars a
year of corruption that occurred during
the last
government and so there is now today a
greater percentage of the money being
handed over at customs points is going
to the central treasury so that helps
the taliban to uh mitigate some of the
the economic uh damage but we're talking
about an economy that has shrunk
considerably uh and so overall uh even
though the taliban are uh consolidating
some of their their power economically
and militarily
yeah it is just a a a
situation of lower demand and so um it's
very difficult for them to to navigate
that you were speaking about them
consolidating power there are still
splits within the taliban and obviously
you alluded also to the previous
government
i wonder whether there have been revenge
killings that one of the biggest
promises that they made in august was
that there would be an amnesty for
people from the previous government that
these revenge killings wouldn't take
place that there would be freedom of the
media as well musker can you give us a
sense of the sentiment there you're
obviously
comfortable speaking to us openly now
what does that say about the situation
maybe i'm just a little brave and i like
taking risks that's why i am staying the
way or speaking rather the way that i am
but media is extremely controlled um
they're not allowed to either it's very
restricted for them they cannot
say everything on the news it's
everything is monitored by the taliban
so um
a lot of what you see on the news it's
probably filtered
and uh unfortunately and um that's just
how it is me speaking the way that i am
is just that my heart aches way too much
to to care about anything happening to
me because my country is falling apart
um and it breaks my heart i cannot i
cannot just sit here and
say
i wish this happened i wish that
happened i'm going to say it as it is
this is barbaric cruel
behavior towards the the people of this
nation as a whole so
graeme let me bring you in briefly on
that how would you assess how genuine
that amnesty offer was and and the state
of of the freedom of the press there now
well the amnesty offer was a great uh
propaganda coup by the taliban because
that was partly i think why
uh their enemies were willing to put
down their guns
in many provinces because the taliban
promised not to kill them
um
it's been enforced unevenly um
the united nations and human rights
watch and other organizations have
identified uh
dozens uh
in some cases more than 100 violations
of the amnesty people have been killed
people been dragged out of their homes
uh it's worth noting though that really
this has been um one of the most
peaceful changes of regime um in the
recent turbulent decades of afghan
history i mean
the last time uh there was when the
taliban were swept out of power
uh you know there were mass killings you
know people mass graves in the desert
and uh we just have not seen
that kind of thing uh although you know
it's difficult to tell from a distance
because exactly as you say um media
reporting uh has been more restricted
you know afghanistan is falling down the
rankings of media freedom um
and uh just you know in the last 24
hours i was receiving messages about
colleagues who were jailed while trying
to photograph and film women's
protesters in the streets now you know
they were eventually released but i was
very worried about them for a few hours
and
you know it's not something that you
would have seen under the previous
government
you're sitting in kabul and i want to
give you the last say as a young woman
in afghanistan right now knowing the
context of what's going on what is your
personal message to the taliban
my personal message would be that we are
not um demanding anything extraordinary
we just want our basic rights given to
us both to women and men
we just want that humanity or or
the basic rights given to us and for it
to be restored uh we're currently the
only country where girls are not going
to school and and i think that's crazy
in the 21st century
basic rights just give us the basic
rights to education health care and
just be nice to to your people in the
end of the day we're all afghans and we
we all just want to live in a peaceful
country where we all work together to
build it into a better better place to
be that's all i can ask for well thank
you for your message musca and thank you
for joining us muska gailani and graham
smith and thank you too for watching you
can see this program again anytime by
visiting our website that's
aljazeera.com and for further discussion
do go to our facebook page that's
facebook.com forward slash aj inside
story remember you can also join the
conversation on twitter we are at aj
inside story for me
tay and the whole team here in doha bye
for now
[Music]